I think good he's educating his immune
system right and so yes so you know I
think you know that that somehow people
I kids are covered with bacteria me your
cover of bacteria so I am NOT a
proponent of you know not getting your
kids vaccinated of not you know taking
baths and washing hands of course of
reasonable you know hygiene right that's
sort of how I live I'm not hysterical
you know like if I do you know about it
and what I do think so what I really
think I think the human body is amazing
it's amazing at how well it works to
make us so infrequently sick but people
don't die from infectious diseases in
this country they don't write a few
thousand people died a year from
infectious diseases and most of them are
old people right whose immune systems
aren't working so well or right you know
and so the human body given the sort of
environment we and I mean Americans by
that live in is amazing at protecting us
and the bacteria are helping with that
but the good ones the ones that are on
on us and so I don't this probably get
you soon I don't use those anti I mean I
and work with bacteria every day I mean
purposely work with back with gobs of
bacteria every day all day it's not
quite that bad but we don't use those
antibacterial soaps soap is fine you
know like I I think you know I just know
i'm always eating it i'm always rubbing
my eyes i'm always you know and i'm
mostly well
I think you have to be vigilant I think
you have to expect your kid is going to
get sick over his or her young life
that's part of how you get a nice immune
system so later when your body isn't as
healthy you're better at coping with
those things but but i think you know
there's seven billion of us you know and
most of us live in conditions that are
so much less hygienic than americans
live in right i think it's a system that
works
you